to welcome everybody to the show
that never sleeps what do you think
[Music]
um good luck it doesn't mean anything it
doesn't mean anything
oh thank you star wishes good luck
welcome everybody to the show
that's always awake it's just
weird okay the show that posts three
maybe sometimes four times a week and
doesn't have
a regular schedule accurate there we go
welcome everybody to hd podcast i am
your host ethan klein with me is my
beautiful wife and co-host eli klein
today we've got a heck of a big team
today we've got a heck of an episode
sponsored by
expressvpn and stamps.com we get a call
in
from the mayor hopeful andrew yang to
announce his candidacy
we're also getting a call in from
shoenice who apparently
we're not unsure if he was at the maga
riot because there's a clip of him
well i'm just saying it looks just like
him so we're gonna find out from him if
he was there or not
yeah um today we're talking about
there's been all kinds of scandals and
stuff i thought we'd just take them all
head-on today
with the predators of youtube the
predators predators predators predators
of youtube
right there's a lot of predators in show
business
um actually just a lot of predators
period
you think so yeah it's in everything
well i guess the problem is in shield
business particularly is that they have
now this the ability to
get at women you know what i mean i
think it's also
just that it's um coming to light a lot
easier nowadays with social media
but right my phone went off
sorry my mom it is
definitely in pretty much everywhere
what's the percentage of men do you
think are like predator prone
oh vin diesel's definitely incredible
one here i don't know it's a sad
conversation
25 50. i've i've seen it a million times
myself in my personal life
i've experienced things um so i feel
like
a lot of men are creeps 50 more less
than 50.
yeah maybe 50. holy [ __ ] that means one
well we know which one of us is
yeah yeah anyway well you know um
my golden rule that i try to tell all
these creators and youtubers and
influencers wherever you are
do not flirt with your freaking fans man
listen if you want to date a fan if you
meet a fan that you like that's one
thing
if you want to just chat and then meet
in person and start dating
that i can sanction i prefer if you
didn't but that i can sanction
but don't be sending dick pics and
asking for boob shots in the goddamn
dm's and for christ's sake
there's so many issues with that but
anyway we'll get into all that
but before you know thank you vin
there's a lot going on in the world
uh and i want to just open with this
statement
that you know is as relevant today as
it's ever been
yoko ono the great wife of john lennon
just as genius i would say as her late
husband john lennon was
dear friends i would like to share this
message with you as my response to
donald trump
and tagged him love yoko so that being
said
you know headphones trigger warning
let's see what yoko has to say about
all the discord happening in our world
today
you know don't you find it interesting
that she inserted this photo of herself
screaming like a maniac that like slowly
pans out
i couldn't have said it better myself
should we note that this this was
actually put out in 2016. yeah
but it was just retweeted uh in light of
recent as relevant as
as it was then it is now yoko said it
best
anyway how are you doing today ela
um fine i guess i don't know the news is
so crazy
i can't stop watching i'm i'm watching
it like in every
possible way listening on the news and
then listening on like political shows
and then no
i can't anymother shows that people
comment about it
it's just crazy you know i'm twitter all
day too
yeah like i haven't closed twitter for a
second it's like during the election it
was like oh i
can't stop i gotta get away from this
and so it's like that all again you know
it's just so crazy like now they're
saying that three members of congress
helped the writers and showed them
around and gave them tours the day
before
yeah there's that one psych this one
there's actually a q anon
lady in congress uh wha what's her name
well there's a couple which one are you
talking about the one that tweeted out
nancy pelosi's location
when she was removed oh so that's the
the the bobert or bobert
or whatever yeah i mean dude how is she
queueing on
yeah she's she's because there's the
other majorie taylor or whatever that
one
she's big time queuing on i know for
sure it's just not sure about it
like i i think america might be dead i
think we have become i was thinking
about this
like last night unironically i think
that we have just become too
[ __ ] dumb we've become too dumb
i don't think there's ever been a time
in history where we become so
[ __ ] pathetically irredeemably dumb
it's like when okay nature wrote god is
dead
yeah america is dead i think america is
dead it's like
you know back in the day this this
country was ah people don't give a [ __ ]
big massive dump you know what i mean
but i do think we're
i think it's just done i think america
is just done it's a dead civilization
because you've got people
cueing on believers in congress
i kind of think that should be a
disqualifying
point right there the people spoke they
[ __ ] elected her
i do like it i've seen what i mean
it's just that's what it is that's who
we are i don't know what to say
it's crazy dude we're irredeemably dumb
and it's just so embarrassing
do you want to show your tick-tock too
yeah like that's kind of like
let me see actually this was it you guys
think i'm partisan i'm pretty sure this
guy's a democrat
he is yeah he was sitting on i think so
i'm not sure i don't know who he is if
you guys have any intel
tell me but i still was watching the
impeachment
um proceedings this morning and i saw
this
i saw this live this [ __ ] idiot i'll
just let it repeat
he takes down his mask
[Music]
and makes a big wet juicy sneeze into
his hand watch this
bro don't you understand that's why
you're wearing a mask you dip
[ __ ] [ __ ] what are you doing that's
literally why
you couldn't spray your germs any
further and wider and more disgusting
than that
why would you take your mask down to
sneeze in your hand we've been through
this we've been doing this for a year
how the [ __ ] do you not know how this
works what are you doing
how do you not know how this works what
are you doing
and he puts it up at least he covered
his mouth i guess he sneezed right into
his hand and there's nothing more
disgusting than that
like a big wet sloppy sneeze you
couldn't see him
even his lip goes like because he got it
was juicy his lip goes
he has to like suck the saliva back
look at this it's so juicy and then it
goes
gross i love the look she gives him yeah
she's like the [ __ ]
that's totally mean and by the way well
he i kept watching he handed her his
phone
later and she took it and she was
looking at something on his phone so
you know what i mean call me
aegis i don't know i don't want any more
old [ __ ] people in common he doesn't
look that old
yeah well he's too [ __ ] old you know
what i saw someone young do it
uh not unrelated to like television but
i saw someone young do it like our age
they're stupid that's just like pretty
close to me
really it took his mask off to sneeze
and then put it back on
i don't i don't know because they feel
like it's gross but it's like exciting
gross that's where it belongs it came
out of your mouth
it should stay there wow
sister snapped okay that's something
james charles would do
i don't know how we redeemed this
society we live in new york
but anyway enough about uh my bitching
and moaning
[Applause]
you know i'll just play just remember
what yoko owner said when you get
discouraged
so you want to talk about the predators
of youtube so there's two i'm talking
about here today
tony lopez and maybe the most
controversial at least in our world call
me carson
which was uh canceling of epic
proportion but
because tony's still blowing up on
twitter people watch that [ __ ] and
nobody really cares somehow about
tony tony lopez one of these guys on
tick tock that actually just gives me
the creeps he's such a little freak
let me pull up his tick tock is my home
right
here's a picture of him he always he the
first time i ever saw tony lopez he was
dancing in the background of
james charles video okay and i was like
that guy's a weird man
i just knew he was a weirdo well i think
you need to show
okay good idea let's pull it up it was
his sir
james charles uh it was the one where he
was doing the duet with that guy and we
were like man this is like
such a wild video oh what are you
singing
yeah where he's singing and then he's
dancing in the background what was that
one called
um i don't you i got my gucci shoes you
got your sketcher
sister my gucci shoes
james charles gucci shoes let's see if
we can find that
yeah here it is you're so in tune with
the youth
yeah well what can i say so here he is
on the right
i wish i could you guys could hear this
because it's like the worst thing ever
[Applause]
so he's been i see his name so this is
him dancing in the back
and this is the first time i saw him and
i was like man this kid ain't right bro
you know what i mean it's just something
ain't right
i got my gucci shoes well you guys got
to hear this it's
the weirdest video i have ever seen in
my life bro
oh yeah and the weird thing is i'm not
gonna get claimed for these [ __ ] but
the the weird thing is that they're
acting like they're outside
but they clearly did the vocals in a
studio and dubbed it
and it's like so weird on candy
[Music]
and then they're like fake laughing and
[ __ ] you gotta watch it
but anyway this guy's a this guy's
apparently like a
straight up a predator bruh
sister send me your nudes i know you're
only 13 years old
let's get crazy wow
anyway you get the idea let's hear james
singh
uh you like james's bodysuit
no what about his little his little
delicate
shorts that you can kind of see his ass
in
yeah they're they're like delicate
shorts you know what i mean
i don't know i'm not a fan i guess not a
fan ela's spoken james you just got
dunked on by a fashion night gun
anyway so that story is
[Music]
that tony lopez
and you know i listen there's no way to
know
without seeing the evidence if he's
guilty or not but
basically all i need to see you know
i mean let's be honest guys this is his
latest tick tock
okay so what more do you really need to
know than this hilo
the man's guilty
what is with this tech talk
the man did it just look at it just
watch like to make love
bruh is that do you think that's how he
flirts he sensed that
oh yeah yay
what kind of tech talk is that seriously
it's a trend where people flex their ass
to a beat so this is a trend
yeah stop still nasty though what's
wrong with you tony lopez
put your ass away freak here's another
one
well that's kind of funny you think
that's funny i don't but like i mean i
can see
that it's funny i can see that tempted
[Music]
um elo you might be falling victim to
the man
i don't like it you don't see him
hitting that whip with that
whoa i've seen other people do it with
like the million underwear
so i'm just saying it's not the worst
thing that i've seen okay that's fair
enough
anyway it's not funny
right everything he does is like weird
and sexual though
it's like slap ass
that's pretty creepy knowing what we
know
here look at this he did it
bro look at him you tell me he didn't do
it
this guy's tripping bro look at those
dude moves like that
you know he [ __ ] a 15 year old
let me hear the music
[ __ ] a 15 year old girl told me your
boobs in the dms yeah
oh
talk to me baby bro you tell me he
didn't do it ela
no let's watch it let's do another one i
like it's fun i like watching
i just people are so popular yeah the
views are crazy right well i don't know
i'm like who are we
to charge i always try this let's get a
load of this
bro is he like two feet tall
not to be sh like yeah whatever i
shouldn't make fun of his height but
like that angle probably you think it's
an angle thing
it takes him a second to get on the
stool because he's
under five feet what that did you
how did you pull that oh my god chris
hanson
he's so on point that was
perfect that was unbelievable zach damn
chris hansen's going after people's
height
he's a little [ __ ] and he can't get on
the stool
his name was tony lopez
that was the best sound i pulled that
one out of the depths man that was great
yeah so that's that one i i i'm kidding
i don't know oh he's five nine he's not
that short
that's not short play that what does
chris hanson think about it's a hater
yeah i'm a hater ass [ __ ] what can i
say it takes him a second to get on the
stool
because he's under five feet tall
we got you tony
oh weirdly specifically how did you find
that
it's the best soundbite ever i've i've
had that in the arsenal forever oh wow
nice so good all right so that's that
one okay whatever
i don't know the truth or whatever but
i'm sure the judge has all the evidence
that they need
i hope they do and i hope they get
justice well if they brought this case
without any of the texts and stuff that
they claim to have them they're [ __ ]
idiots and the case should be thrown out
you know
right but that that's that one
the next one this one is
there's no whatever if she said this one
we know what happened okay
because call me carson admits to it now
call me carson he was like
a huge rising star beloved by all right
and this is one of these rare cases on
youtube where
the 180 is insane it's like beloved call
me carson
we love call me carson you know what he
looks like
no i'll show you pick he always he's
kind of like
here i'll just show you you might become
he has like this goofy yearbook photo
that he's always really fun
i have seen that yeah he's always kind
of making fun of the way he looks
yeah anyway uh
they love call me carson he is so
funny and we love him yeah this is just
this is the kind of stuff he does
so carson king has been accused of
grooming and inappropriate texting with
fans and we know this because
people from his former group of
collaborators
the lunch club which i guess is a group
of people used to make videos with
took this story to keemstar
the most respectable and reputable place
to report sensitive stories like this
so anyway a twitter user
alleged that he who is now
21 years old groomed her when she was 17
and he was 19.
she posted screenshots and videos that
appear to show message between herself
and king
some of sexual nature
she said the messages began when she
jokingly tweeted be my boyfriend at king
who she says then messaged her privately
he's like okay you know
i was watching someone stream i forget
who and i saw
all these thirsty messages like that and
it's like
guys you cannot you can't
do it you can't do it i saw it was all
like daddy
message me be my boyfriend and it's like
bro you can't do it any you can't do
that [ __ ] so here's what she
here's a so this girl uh
posted on twitter saying that she was
groomed
well i'll just read it i could
personally come out and say that i've
been groomed by
carson i have talked to many people and
never came out about this since now
at the time i was still 17 and in high
school and apparently at the time this
happened he was 19.
right yes so actually here's some of the
messages which
i'll read for you i'm scared i want to
talk to you for the wrong reasons
elaborate should i do like elaborate no
don't do that
okay what if i only want to talk to you
for the sexual part of it
i don't want that but like i'm worried
about it
what if subconsciously i'm only talking
to you because it turns me on or
something bro
why are you even geez man weird
is that really what you want what other
options are there
also what would you want to happen i
don't know all i know is every time i
jack off now i have a really hard time
not thinking of you
he's a romantic
was this valentine's day or what
god dude what the [ __ ]
i guess my brain got stimulated and now
wants more of you you know
sorry i was in school but yeah yeah
people were goofing on that because
i don't know i read that and i was like
oh
it's like every time i jack off i think
about you
and i want more and she's like sorry was
that school what'd you say
yeah i know it's kind of a red flag
there
he said uh what if we read on snap and
next time you're horny we have some fun
again oh god it's so
[ __ ] cringy and gross
i just don't want to be the only thing
we do you know so she's kind of pushing
back a little bit
yeah but [ __ ] sam you're hard to resist
so are you i feel like this is all my
fault damn
if anything it's my fault because i
can't control myself
[ __ ] hell i want to but it's a bad
idea
i'm not gonna lie i'm scared getting
your hopes up or something
i'm willing to try but it's such a bad
idea
but so is sexting you [ __ ]
and he also asked her when do you turn
18
which you know kind of shows that he
knows what he's doing
so yeah it's um definitely a weird
creepy conversation ugh i've it's like
so any here's an important thing to say
is that she feels like she was
you know mistreated by him she was
groomed by him so
that's important
using the internet without expressvpn is
like going to the bathroom and not
closing the door
internet providers like comcast or
verizon know every single website you
visit
and isps can sell this information to ad
companies and tech giants who then use
your data to target you
[ __ ] that nobody's targeting me
expressvpn creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet
so your line online activity can't be
seen by anyone
it's as easy as closing the bathroom
door
you know my dad once said this thing he
uh
[Music]
i don't know why he's just like stab
[ __ ] we're like wherever he pees he
leaves the door open
and he comes to our house and he pees
with the door open
isn't that insane that's like that's
it's insane right
like ela's there though i'm like i don't
think he does it on purpose he just
doesn't think
i'm like that close the [ __ ] door man
this is easy exp it's turning expressvp
on
at vpn vpn on
fire up the app with just one click of a
button rated number one by
cnet wired and the verge it works on
phones
laptops even routers so everyone who
shares your wi-fi can be protected
i love expressvpn it's a game changer
for me
because for example i like to watch
netflix
and canada in japan they've got
you know all this badass [ __ ] there's
nothing worse than getting rejected from
a streaming service that says sorry we
don't serve people in your region like
okay
well all of a sudden i'm on expressvpn
and i'm in canada so you serve now [ __ ]
that's why i love expressvpn secure your
online activity by visiting
expressvpn.com
h3 today that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
h3 and you can get an extra three months
for free
one more time that's expressvpn.com
h3
one thing we've learned in 2020 the
internet is even more awesome than we
thought
groceries online movies online
doctor visits you guessed it online but
of course going to the post office
online with stamps.com
is something we all need to be thinking
about doing as well stamps.com allows
businesses to do all their mailing and
shipping right from their computer
no need to leave their home anymore or
office or home office
stamps.com has saved small businesses
all
over the country thousands of hours and
tons of money and now you can too with
stamps.com
sams.com you get the service of the post
office and ups right
on your computer plus you get big
discounts on mailing and shipping rates
[Music]
sense.com brings the service to the us
postal office and ups right to your
computer wherever you are
stamps.com is a must-have for any
business whether your small office
sending out invoices
or an online seller shipping out orders
or even a giant warehouse sending
thousands of packages a day
stamps.com can handle it all with these
simply use your computer to print
official us postage 24 7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you damn well want
once your mail is ready just schedule a
pickup or drop it off it's that simple
with sams.com you get five cents off
every first class stamp and up to 40
off priority mail and up to 62 percent
off with ups shipping grades
not to mention it's a fraction of
acosta's expensive postage meters i
still know what that means
but i'm assuming whoever knows what it
means knows what it means you know what
i
mean
what is a postage meter stamps.com is a
no-brainer
saving you time and money it's no wonder
over 900
000 small businesses already use
stamps.com
so make 2020 one the year you stop
wasting time going to the post office
and go to stamps.com instead
there's no risk and with my promo code
h3
you get a special offer that includes
nine week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
there's no long-term commitment or
contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in h3 that's stamps.com promo
code
h3 sams.com never go
to the post office again
[Music]
but the other thing is like
it's just this power dynamic bro you can
do this with your fans because
yeah you're not a normal person right
like they're
it's just [ __ ] up to do this also you
when aren't do you turn 18 if you find
yourself asking a girl
when do you turn 18 you're you're [ __ ]
up
yeah or if you just told her that you
can't wait to jack off and think about
her and she's like sorry i'm
i'm it's cool yeah i can't wait to take
your class
i read it it's like furious he goes
by the way girls on valentine's day take
a page out of carson's book
uh all i know is every time i check off
now
i have a really hard time thinking about
you
stop i'm gonna send you i'm gonna send
you a card that says that
i think about you when i took off
lovely i feel like it's angry
but you know what like when i think um
the moments that give me that grooming
feeling is like when
when he makes himself the victim he's
like oh [ __ ] i don't want to do this but
i can't help myself and then she's like
oh i'm sorry
i feel like it's my fault that's a
really good point that's grooming
right you know what i mean that's when
making her feel her feelings
yeah she's feeling bad for him it's like
no
hmm that is a really good point and you
only understand that when you're a
little bit older you look back at it and
you're like oh
what was he doing what was he doing to
me
i totally think you're onto something
there that's a really good insight
so that was this one girl there was
apparently another girl
that this happened with let's see um
the allegations have been discussed in a
video by keemstar
who interviewed two of his former lunch
club
collaborators i can't get over that i'm
sorry like
so he says the story is uh horrifying on
him being creepy
the story of his friends going star of
all people
now one of his friends who didn't go on
keemstar said
when i heard that something happened i
just reported it to the authorities he's
like good on you
who i mean the fact that you went to
keemstar with this says a lot about you
i mean who are these people why keemstar
that just means you want the guy to end
up killing himself
you're not trying to help anyone by
going to keemstar yeah and of course
because
then keep starting making 20 videos keep
starts calling him a pedophile which of
course like let's be honest he's not a
pedophile
i'm sorry keemstar is not i don't know
called him a pedophile
i'll walk that back but people are
calling him a pedophile
and that's just like grooming and
manipulative and flirting with
and sexting with fans all very serious
seen also people talk about the power
dynamic and
you know there's a lot of debate around
that i agree like you know if you're a
youtuber and you have fans that look up
to you
and they'll do anything for you and then
you go to those underage fans and start
soliciting nudes
no matter how old you are where it's
like you know when you're listening to
the news it's a crime i think that's a
[ __ ] up
situation thank you keemstar it's bad
facts when he's right
mine's right making sense yeah when he's
like you know that meme where it's like
the worst person you know
made a good point yeah
now the question is did keemstar defend
pro jared when
that is exactly what i was thinking this
makes me think about the pro jared thing
where everyone's like
pro jared is innocent even though he had
a forum called sin
jared where he exchanged nudes with fans
i mean
get wrap your brain around his situation
call me carson look like
yeah tame in comparison pro
jared is the r kelly of fan sexting
he's prolific or maybe the bill cosby i
don't know what you want to see the kobe
bryant
the michael jordan they're just really
good at it
why are we dragging people into this i'm
not saying there's anything wrong
i'm just saying they excelled at their
sport kobe
he was the kobe bryant of sexting
that doesn't sound good why i think it
makes sense
you guys on board with that stop stop
to some of his uh close friends
explaining like
hey this needs to come out like people
need to know about close friends
and they want to come out but they were
worried about how to come out and how to
say it so they came to me
drab alert anyway
so yadda yadda bottom line
is that it sounds like the age gap was
not
big two years which does kind of put the
situation in a little bit of a different
light i think
but the behavior is
one of uh creepy nature and predatory i
think
definitely predatory the problem is that
like even though they're only two years
apart
it's still very young women 17 years old
is these women don't not making the best
choices at that age
yeah but then again at 19 you're not
either but the problem is
that he has that authority and as
keemstar
absolutely put you cannot be soliciting
nudes
when you are in that spot where people
looking up to you so
definitely shame on carson creepy
disgusting uh behavior by him
i really just and i will say i'm going
to come out and say
disgusting weird [ __ ] up everybody's
friends to go take this to keemstar like
holy [ __ ]
yeah like it wasn't like we need to get
this out
we need to make sure he's not doing
anything
no they're like we need to run on his
life yeah we want him to die
basically it's what happens when they go
to keemstar you know um
traves one of the guys went to keemstar
said
oh is that he spelled travis why is it
t-r-a-v-e-s
i've never seen travis spelled like that
trades
the [ __ ] trades i knew that
felt weird
why don't you say earlier like ethan's
been saying in the whole episode
good point anybody
want to answer that i thought it was
traves i mean it's it's spelled like
trades
it says phrase why why do you think it's
travis
ian you want to answer that i don't know
that just sounds
off i agree i think his name is actually
trained
can we get a ruling on this i mean if
your name is travis articles
said i feel like the situation was kind
of like he told us all this crazy
thing and we didn't want to make a rash
judgment oh so you waited a year and
then went to keemstar dumbass
so we didn't want to make a rash
judgment so we wait we kind of waited it
out and we were trying to think of the
best solution to do
i understand waiting but your best
solution was going to keemstar bro i
don't buy that
we pushed it away and we kept pushing it
away because we didn't want to deal with
it
noah also told keemstar that carson's
behavior is what caused the lunch club
to break up
okay hours after keemstar video went
live former lunch club member
uh slimesicle said in a statement on
twitter and earlier
no i'm just kidding stop slime's the
call
i actually said a name right can you
give me a [ __ ] brick an early 2020
phone call carson told all the lunch
members
and our group manager they'd exchange
nudes with an un
named girl he believed to be 17. because
i suspected a crime had been committed
i immediately reported this information
to federal law enforcement
caught all ties to carson and withdrew
completely from the lunch club
there is a responsible man slimesicle
uh real name is travis so there might be
something
next to that but but he goes by i mean
it's spelled traves i mean what do you
want yeah
and his name is travis you really
brought this show to a hall bro with
your old travis [ __ ]
his real name is travis so yeah but i
think that must be his uh
nickname how does how does keemstar say
it in the interview
i'm listening to the interview now okay
all right when you hear it
does he have a channel of his mr romeo
and julia
who's gonna tell us how to pronounce
this romeo and juliet
i haven't read romeo and juliet that's
that's like the name of the porn version
romeo and juliet
okay uh
s a c scoop also post statement on
twitter later on tuesday and said i said
my piece about the carson situation
yesterday under the pretense that would
be used in keem's video but
it wasn't i didn't feel well enough
mentally at the time to be interviewed
well you don't have to only impress your
[ __ ] be on keemstar
show that's for sure update what keeps
going said
travis travis it is
yeah but keem i guess we owe you an
apology
trey look at him gloating there look at
that smile
now i'm sorry for halting things i mean
you really [ __ ] the show
up dude i forget what we're even talking
about well there's no winning yet
because if you are right you should have
said it earlier
what do you say so keem said uh romeo
and julie so
or julia right that's what i would say
can you keep searching maybe for
different
regardless of if it's travis or not you
spell your name trades dude you can't be
upset that people say trades yeah that's
not how travis is spelled yeah it's
literally
well how is his name spelled if you go
to like wikipedia or his page like how
is it is his name spelled differently
his real name is travis
which is spelled how like like you would
spell travis so it's spelled differently
yeah with a with an eye so his nickname
is traves i'm understanding
yeah and if if it's still i thought we
were talking about carly carson
i thought so too i don't know we're lost
what's the does that guy have a youtube
channel he does i don't know what it is
his name is but this is his channel he
presents as travs or traits that's the
name of the channel traits
but did you hear him say are you just
going off the spelling or how
what's the name of the channel the name
of the travel is trades
just slaves just trying to traipse yes
i'm waiting i'm trying to find a video
of him
okay ella's pulling up trades
okay here it says traipse but
so that that's the point what's his real
name how's his real name spelled
he's not spelling it his real name is
spelled travis as you would normally
spell travis so this is real
traits it's tracy that's what i i agree
it has to be traded regardless
of how he pronounces it his name is
traves
i'm declaring that right now either i
think it's
true no oh treves actually no i just
made that up i don't know
okay from wicked wikitubia
uh it says travis better known online as
traves
you're still just going off text the
point is no
no no no no no he's wrong he's right
why what how else would you are you
supposed to read that he says his name
is travis he goes that's trade
i agree that the spelling clearly says
trades yeah and so ian
threw a rank for the whole [ __ ] thing
and
also the fact that keemstar can't read
properly
only validates our point that it's
traced
right and not true but technically
keemstar is right his name is travis
right technically
so anyway this is the biggest
bigger scandal than this i'm going on
can't i'm going a
drama like to expose this [ __ ]
so anyway this guy trades
i got it go ahead i'm sorry i found a
video that starts off
and it goes hi my name is travis oh
great
that's it so what is it why did he
change the spelling then
what does it mean when he says his name
is travis and he goes as travis that
doesn't make any sense my name is travis
his name is travis but it says at trades
this doesn't
this doesn't solve anything his name is
travis it's like the cool way of
spelling it let's
just separate tra vest travis
travis it's not it doesn't make any
sense to go on his page and say
my name is travis i go as travis that
doesn't make sense you know what
it's on the pan that's not what he said
it said he goes by
trades his name is travis he goes by
trade play it again
no not on this on the [ __ ] wiki
youtube page
yeah yeah his real name give me the poll
give me that link
give me the [ __ ] link this makes no
sense wait i'll show you
it's travis it's traves no
it is trey he just said travis wait
no but he said that's his name his name
is travis
it says here look fandom wiki
lunch club it says
what do you what do you think the first
line of it says travis known as
and then spelled the weird way treves
it just says trade though i know the
spelling it
travis look at ela right here let me put
it on the screen this is so stupid we
should just cut this
no this is the best part people are
gonna love this
travis right better known online as
trade so why the [ __ ] would they say
better known as phrase
by the spelling because you made
surprises
travis better known as travis that
doesn't make any sense
because you'll see him spelled like that
so better known as
this is what it's going why would he
misspell his own name maybe he wanted to
maybe the handle wasn't available
yeah exactly or seo you gotta find him
saying his channel name that's the only
solution he said travis
but he said my name is travis not my
channel name it's trade it's true
that's true because he's doing like a
biographical thing like hi my name is
ethan i would introduce myself and say
hi i'm h2s3 production i say hi i'm
ethan
right that's true okay my name's travis
i'm gonna put this on the screen so you
guys can see
hey my name is travis and one of my
friends did a sex crime so i went to
keemstar
my name is travis and i'm 19 and i'm
lunch
[Music]
hey my name's travis and every time i
witness a crime i take us directly to
[Music]
but keemstar needs to get the ball in
this stat
travs travs that seems like an
appropriate nickname okay i'm over this
i want to cut it you guys think it
should stay
it absolutely should be so stupid
i'm over it so travis
travis drops if anyone can actually get
a conclusive answer
it's just oh you know his fans are going
to be in the comments
while screaming about it if baby figures
it out let me know i'm gonna keep
reading
so trev said he wanted to listen
i'm saying trades until i hear others
i'm actually with you [ __ ] [ __ ] traffic
if you were reporting on yourself for
example you would just say ethan right
so just say travis
it says traves trav said travis
the guy respected the travis he said
he said i don't want to make a rash
judgment so i thought about it for a
year and then decided the best thing to
do was go to keemstar with it
that just tells you that there's a
problem with our society
because the problem is our society
because him
19 year old got this information that
his friend is doing something wrong
and he doesn't even know what to do with
it and the best
the best solution in his mind is to go
to someone like keemstar so you're
saying i shouldn't be so harsh on him
it's just society's fault yeah
interesting
all right i forgive you uh travis
roberts
travis travis travis
i forgive you travis you should start
going by you should have known better i
feel like you should have known better
but okay
he didn't do anything wrong you know
what i mean he didn't do the thing you
do
he's fine they're fun so anyway
hours after blah blah blah yeah yeah
i've heard after keemstar video went
live
this other guy said he went to
authorities uh uh
creamsicle or [ __ ] goosical what's
his name
so stupid this is off the [ __ ] rails
where am i creamsicle um
[Music]
kind of feel like slimesickle
[Laughter]
that was his name right yes
okay what were you saying i don't know i
was i kind of have this feeling like
anytime there's like a creator group
there's always something going to go
wrong with that group don't join a
creator group
ever yeah i guess the vlogs the vlog
squad is relatively
true with them right didn't trisha have
a bunch of drama with them
yeah but no crimes let's say okay except
maybe the
the puzzle that may have been a crime
no we figured it out he had a proper
legal loophole to get away okay can i
stick to the [ __ ] story we're like
we're trying to
we have a narrative here right we're
talking about carson okay another
allegation came out
twitter user uh copycat
put out a statement saying that she was
what the [ __ ] dan she said what it says
copycat
copycat well it's spelled weird it's
spelled c-o-p-i-i-c-h
all these creators with these weird ass
names you expect me just to be able to
read that like [ __ ] you
i'm i'm with you i'm with you put out a
stop i'm saying [ __ ] you copycat
that that thank you joe she put out a
statement saying that she was exchanging
this is serious you guys can we please
[Laughter]
she put out a message saying that she
was 17 and he was
20. a little wider age gap
according to keemstar also you know what
worries me here
that he aged a year and went back to a
17 year old
yeah that does that is worrisome it's
like uh
it's uh confused yeah exactly it's like
uh mcconaughey said
i love high school girls i keep getting
older and they stay the same age
that's kind of call me carson doing that
right now
so this was her she said a second
accuser's come forward
hashtag dramaalert of course good guy
keem whatever
may through june 9th 2019
started when he shared my grad photo on
insta he shared my grad photo on insta
i was 17 at the time of these exchanges
and he was 20.
there's more but the ig account i have
was deleted so here let me read oh sorry
let me put this on the screen
here let me see it's really small hey
you there i want to drop the sexual
stuff entirely
stop bro oh my god he does the same
thing he did with the other girl
i've been it's been making me feel sick
thinking about it
i feel wrong for having done it and i
feel like i've led you on
i enjoy talking to you and all but it's
just
too much and i feel really guilty so i'm
sorry
i've i've also realized that i have a
crush on my friend
sarah oh god it's like he's dumping her
it's not like i feel bad why are you
telling her this
i have a crush on my friend sarah and i
don't want to lead you on
in any way tomorrow i'm starting my trip
to california and i think i just
need to move on now so it's not like i
feel bad for getting nudes from my
underage girl it's i'm dumping you
and then again like you said ela he goes
on to make himself the victim
i'm very stressed and talking to you has
been adding extra stress
and i'm very scared and i feel bad about
wanting to un-add you it's just a lot
right now
and i'm not sure talking to you is a
good
decision by the way i'm reading really
slow because it's so small
are you impressed that i can even read
that i have no idea how you can read
that
i have super i have supervision thank
you very much
so good luck yeah thank you you
if you ask me
and i'm not an expert but if you ask me
what what grooming is that's what i see
hmm so yeah that like for sure
making yourself the victim and it's it's
like a mind manipulation because you
make them feel bad for you
right and he got what he wanted from her
and then he like makes her feel bad for
him
mm-hmm it's like i'm gonna unblock you
now i'm not i'm gonna
add you now yeah it's like fine and also
i got this other girl
that's weird bro well we did establish
that is a
romantic yeah he is romantic
i have to assume that he's done this to
sever to many girls
this is kind of a pattern um
oh he has defenders some of king's
defenders have argued that the
interaction between king
and both accusers are legal under the
romeo and juliet law
which typically allows well apparently
it doesn't apply to people over 18 but
whatever it's not really in debate
whether it's illegal or not that isn't
really what's at issue
i guess it is for keemstar but i mean
you can't se
you it you can't sext underage girls i
think the exchanging of the pictures
yeah that's that's that's the thing that
got crossed yeah
uh that part of like exchanging nudes
that's
alleged how i think it's
the girls say that they sex and the guy
says that he
the guys who told keemstar said that he
admitted
exchanging nudes with them yeah so but
okay so that's all weird
right and that all makes him seem super
creepy and
gross and stuff but this to me
is the weirdest part of the story that
gives me the creeps
way more than any one of those now you
guys tell me what you think about this
now kia now carson has a steam account
and he people started discovering
something really odd about his steam
account
okay and after people discovered this he
started trying to hide his steam account
and changing his name and all this stuff
but so there's this game
that was removed from the steam store
called pregnancy
which is about which is about a girl who
you play as a girl it's such a weird
[ __ ] game you play as a girl who's
was raped when she's 14 years old and
decides and you have to choose the
outcome of your pregnancy
it was super yeah a super weird messed
up game that was removed from steam
because it's just [ __ ] up but here's
the kicker the game apparently
only takes 40 minutes to finish carson
played it for 107 hours
i saw like i'm not even gonna show it
but i saw people playing it on youtube
and it's like really graphic
gross reclaiming of like rape and stuff
yeah and this [ __ ] played this
game for 107 hours y'all
that's a lot right like i'm not i'm not
a gamer
but a game that takes that sounds like a
lot of followers well i'll put it i'll
put it to you this way you play it over
100 times
let me put it to you this way um
like skyrim is probably the game i
played the clock the most hours on
like in my adult life i think i put like
50 hours into that
yeah that's bizarre
that's weird right you guys yeah i mean
if it
the game takes 40 minutes to finish is
what it says and you play
107 hours how many times are you
replaying this game over and over and
over and over again
yeah yeah pretty well yeah that to me
creeping out way more than anything else
and so once people started figuring this
out he like was trying to hide his thing
and change his steam and close his team
and all this and yeah
but anyway he had the public what a
weird game yeah what though yeah i mean
there's there's a
there's steam always has really weird
[ __ ] like that come through
uh-huh you know i've heard of other
games like that that steam ends up
removing but damn dude hundreds of
[ __ ] hours
people say you could have left it open
or he could have done this but
he played that [ __ ]
you can see how many achievements you
have in a game i wonder if anybody was
able to
dig up if he uh 100 of it
so what do you think of all this tony
lopez and call me carson
i'm pretty over it
i wish that people would be more
responsible stop even if you
are a creep and whatever just at least
like have some
self preserv inclination of self
preservation and don't flirt with fans
like that
don't sex with fans like that you know
what i mean like it's just
dumb it's just a dumb thing to do come
on dude it's just irresponsible
you got it you're famous go get a date
man it's easy to date when you're famous
and rich and whatever like
you don't have to sex with minors bro go
get a [ __ ] date you
dip [ __ ] you know what i mean
damn the marvel of the story is really
the same world i've been saying to
everybody it's like
christalia who else is
this happening to all pro jared pro
jared oh the one thing i wanted to say
is like
i think call me carson was creepy
grooming for sure
sexting with minors and fans for sure
disgusting behavior
but for some reason everybody let pro
jared off the hook
and pro jarrod's behavior is like more
disgusting than carson's the guy
made a private tumbler called sin jared
specifically for fans to come exchange
nudes with him
i mean that is next level disgusting and
everybody forgive pro jared
and i'd never understood that i never
understood that
to me what pro jr did as is disgusting
as anything i've ever heard
well that's not it's not as anything
i've ever heard but in terms of what's
coming out of youtube like compared to
call me carson and all this other stuff
it's like you have a forum dead it's
called i mean dude sin jared i mean what
the [ __ ] that
name alone yo hit me up on sin jared bro
where he did do this stuff with underage
people although his news were all over
twitter
yeah i've seen his dick like many times
yeah
and like i mean guys i don't understand
the whole forgiving pro
sin jared you should be called cinder
now so nasty
god yeah people got very upset at us for
that one even
well i assume stand by i never
criticized pro
sin jared for like i know there was some
story that ended up being
not true about him uh
i i don't remember what how what it was
but i i never really latched on to that
because there was very little evidence
to support it the sin jared [ __ ] is what
creeped me out and that's all i ever
talked about and i stand by the fact
that
that that dude ain't right and by the
way he's like older too
how old is sin jared he's in his
thirties he asked me i
wanna say he's around sorry that [ __ ] is
what buckwild dude
35. that [ __ ] is 35 running
around sin
jared making gaming content dude
yeah i found it super weird that click
his logo i want to see his face he grew
some facial hair
bruh he looks better with facial hair
actually
i did find it super weird that people
just let him off the hook on that i
don't know
because all these [ __ ] to your
commentary channels were like he raped a
girl
they were like they they latched on to
this ridiculous drama story
that ended up not being true that was
never really the story the real story
you know right you're right and then it
all kind of got conflated
the [ __ ] insured creepy cinder is a
creepy [ __ ]
anyway whatever nobody cares
ethan get a [ __ ] life stop gossiping
no this is my show and i'll do what i
want if you don't like it
well i hope that you're patient and wait
because i don't want you to not watch
something else
it's very important to me that you guys
keep watching right ela
right and i apologize actually all right
let's move it on
you know we've got uh andrew yang
calling in a little bit later and shoe
nice to answer for
apparently he was writing in the capital
so we're gonna get to the bottom of that
but before that
i thought i would commemorate trump's
twitter
being banned with some of his greatest
tweets of all time
this is not political i promise you this
is just good lighthearted fun
these tweets go all the way back to the
beginning of his twitter account before
many people were even
you know following a lot of these only
have like a couple hundred likes
and his tweets i'm telling you man these
things are
slam dunks this guy really was the god
of twitter
i mean for example here this one goes
back to 2014. i only have 300 likes
rosie is back on the view which tells
you how desperate they must be
it is the standard short-term fix and
long-term disaster
gossiping about the view 300 likes
awesome it's really the next part though
rosie is crude
rude obnoxious and dumb other than that
i like her very much
i mean that's [ __ ] hilarious
you know what i mean i love that he's
just oh he's just on a rampage
about rosie o'donnell nothing better
today i
never understood how melania's thing was
to end bully
oh my god when she's
i just don't understand how is it
possible
i don't think they thought it through
very well
every first lady apparently needs some
cause and hers was like ah bullying
i don't think she ever even did anything
about it
be best bro well everyone was saying
trump's account being suspended was the
she finally said the best accomplishment
more rosie he is really obsessed with
her
i feel sorry for rosie's new partner in
love whose parents are devastated the
thought of the daughter being with rosie
a true loser oh my god
this is vicious he tagged her too you
know if i read this at the time like
this guy is
off his [ __ ] rocker he's at and rosie
why does he hate rosie so much
they had a feud for a long time really
yeah
yeah he hates her man that's awesome
thousand likes
this guy became president it's awesome
it's freezing and snowing in new york we
need global warming and i mean yeah i've
heard a lot of people say stuff like
that
i'm han i am a handwriting analyst
no you're not 26 likes
this is from janu this is from 2013.
i am a handwriting analyst jack lew's
handwriting shows while strange
that he is very secretive not
necessarily what the [ __ ] is he talking
about
i had to look it up jack lew was the
treasury secretary for obama for a
couple years
and so his signature was on the money
you know the treasury secretaries
so he's giving a little commentary as a
handwriting analyst
everybody knows he's a handwriting
analyst i mean have you seen trump's
signature
you want to talk about a bomb i like it
really
i mean it's a little out there but i
like it here what
looks like a cycle to me well it might
be true
here that i like it
you like that kind of you see my
signature
yeah that's a little crazy it looks like
this is like
one ugly signature first of all and
second of all i get
like i like it i like it awful vibes
from it it looks like a heart rhythm
like machine heart the rhythm of a
serial killer
it could be well he's a handwriting
analyst so who are you
all right this one's from 2013 actually
had a lot of likes
sorry losers and haters but my iq is one
of the highest
and you all know it please don't feel
stupid or insecure it's not your fault
[Music]
i mean i think a lot of the older ones
that have a lot of likes got a lot of
likes because they got retweeted in my
time yeah that makes sense yeah
at ariana huff is unattractive both
inside and out
i fully understand why her former
husband left her for a man
he made a good decision that is just so
[ __ ] up
and he at her too so she can see it yeah
like that is so insanely vicious yeah
oh my god dude he is straight up
has the mentality of like a a playground
bully
yeah i never grew out of that barney
frank
looking barney frank looked disgusting
nipples protruding in his blue shirt
before congress
very very disrespectful what do you want
him to do
donald you want him to wear like nipple
nipple covers or something you should
maybe look up the picture though because
it is a really funny picture
okay so maybe he's onto something barney
frank
nipple if you just do nipple it'll come
up
really this is uh this is the infamous
photo huh
oh what the [ __ ] is this no that's
photoshopped i think
no that's not photoshopped no
that is kind of disrespectful to show up
in front of congress with that
he's not very dressed up is he it's very
bizarre he's just wearing a t-shirt and
he has the
the coat just kind of hanging like a
cake yeah that's not an appropriate
shirt to wear
on congress floor well trump called him
out i'm gonna agree with trump on this
one
barney frank looked disgusting nipples
protruding in his blue shirt before
congress
huh came on a little heavy but
it's like trump have you looked at
yourself yeah he's a [ __ ] man you're
gonna talk about disgusting
but i mean okay the thing i think he has
a point that you have to kind of dress
to your body
yeah that's what he does dress to his
body very well
does he yeah i think so he hides he
hides very well and he's massive
show the photos of him golfing when the
butt is uh
portraiting i'm just yeah i'm i i have
to give the man credit where he's due he
dresses
to his body well
all right like he's massive
but when he's in you know when he's in a
suit
doing his president thing he covers it
up
but he has a dump truck for sure
and well my comment is not just if he's
dressing to his body it's like the fact
that he
goes on and talks about how everyone is
disgusting oh rosie
here's a rosy tweet to donald so
apparently they're going back and forth
donald you disgusting psychopath
may karma kick your orange ass every
moment
nobody likes me oh this is recent oh so
the feud continues
continued oh my god i loved it they're
still feuding
i had to beat off lightweight marco
rubio was working hard last night the
problem is he is a choker and once a
choker always a choker mr meltdown
why would kim jong-un insult me by
calling me old when i would never call
him short and fat
oh well i try so hard to be his friend
and maybe someday that will happen this
was while he was president i remember
tweet
this was right after he went and met
with him in person and
see how it says from vietnam
look it's funny but also god damn you're
the president bro get your [ __ ] together
you're not supposed to communicate with
other world leaders on twitter
robert so now he's talking about robert
pattinson is that the guy
oh okay this is the guy from twilight
now he's talking about twilight yeah the
new the new batman too
robert pattison should not take back
kristen stewart gila
she cheated on him like a dog and we'll
do it again
just watch he can do much better
interesting take mr president
i mean i think like that is funny from
someone who's not the president
yeah this was in what 2011 23. he was
like at the time he tweeted us he was
probably like 65
60. you know what i mean he could do
much better
donald's team robert pattison pattinson
pattinson
wow senator ted cruz that is some low
level ad you did using a picture of
melania and gq
shoot be careful i will spill the beans
on your wife
i don't know what that means he
constantly was insulting ted cruz's wife
which makes it funnier that ted cruz is
like a total
psychopath now yeah he called his wife
an ugly dog and said his dad murdered
jfk
weird i would like to extend my best
wishes to all
even the haters and losers on the
special date september 11th
one of the all-time great tweets i have
to say
like why are you wishing
everybody the best on this special day
even the haters and losers like it's not
it's
amazing tweet wow jeb bush whose
campaign is a total disaster had to
bring in mommy to take a slap at me not
nice
sad sack jeb bush has just done another
ad on me with special interest money
saying i won't beat hillary i will but
he can't beat me
okay well that's not that bad he was
right about that
thank you kanye very cool
gone down an infamy of course
has anyone looked at the really poor
numbers of vanity fair magazine way down
big trouble dead grade in carter no
talent we'll be out i don't know what
the [ __ ] this is
well so this takes a little bit of
context this guy graydon carter was the
editor-in-chief for uh vanity fair
magazine just kind of a new york
socialite guy like
donald trump and trump [ __ ] hates
this guy and tweeted at him
all the time insulting him making fun of
him
telling him he's a loser telling him
he's washed up or whatever
and i looked into it and apparently this
all started because in 1984
graydon carter said that donald trump's
hands were small
and he never forgave him and decades
later
was just absolutely hell-bent on ruining
this guy's life
this is where the hand small thing came
from this is where it all originated
interesting wow vanity fair was totally
shut out at the national magazine awards
it got
nothing great and carson is a loser with
bad food restaurants
rumor has it that the grubby head of
feeling vanity fair magazine
sloppy grade and carter is going to be
fired or replaced very soon
if any fair could come back if great
incarcerant paid as much attention as he
does
to his bad food restaurants jesus
grade and carter is a major loser just
ask his wife
i have watched sloppy grade and carter
fail and close by magazine and now i'm
watching him
jesus [ __ ] he's a total loser wrong
graydon carson has no talent and it
looks like [ __ ]
also his food sucks brand new fair
editor grade and carter allowed to run
bad food restaurant patrice and
fire grade [ __ ] grade and carter are
failing vanity fair magazine
and owner of bad food restaurants has a
problem
his vf oscar party is no longer hot
now finally i had to include this
grand carter though he had a twitter
account had never tweeted
he put out his first tweet about an hour
after trump got banned
oh really oh interesting i thought it
might be a good time for my first tweet
a collector's item so what did i miss
interesting that's funny tip tap dancing
on his graves
okay very special will miss trump on
twitter there's no doubt about that
for his wonderful insights such as
kristen stewart could definitely do
better
no no he could
trump is team edward team edward
and one other thing before we go to our
our special interviews
um has it that this guy
ghosts are we've talked about gosar in
the past
he's a congressman who is allegedly
paul ghoster they can't um helped the
rioters
in the days leading up to the capital
riot
um they're claiming and i'm leading to
something this is really good
apparently activists and conspiracy
theorists who has merged as leaders have
stopped the steel
claimed that they had help from mr
brooks mr gosar
and representative andy biggs okay
now this is now we've heard of gosars
we've been warned before you guys may
remember we
we watched this video paul gosar the
congressman
isn't doing anything the most brutal
the most brutal attack ad ever
put on television ever ever
we call we call this at the time getting
ghost art because i've never seen
anything so brutal in my life
now they warned us about gosar and here
it is again for for your
memory and viewing pleasure closer the
congressman
isn't doing anything to help rural
america
paul's absolutely not working for his
district if they care about health care
they care about their children's health
care they would hold him to account
if they care about jobs they would hold
him to account
if he actually cared about people in
rural arizona
i bet he'd be fighting for social
security for better access to health
care
i better he i bet he would be
researching what is the most insightful
water policy
to help the environment of arizona
sustain itself
and be successful and he's not listening
to you
and he doesn't have your interests at
heart my name is tim gosar david gosar
grace gosar
joan gosam gaston gosar jennifer gosar
paul gosar's my brother my brother
and i endorsed dr grill dr bill
wholeheartedly
endorsed his whole [ __ ] family dr
david
went on record against him for this guy
dr brill whoever the [ __ ] dr brill's a
cut ass [ __ ] god throw this [ __ ]
this whole ad is so vicious i wonder if
it backfired
i want a documentary about that i want
to know more
what happened with this family that all
of them came together
on a public ad to say my brother is the
worst person on earth
he's still one despite that you know
what i mean i just looked it up not only
did he won
he won 68 percent to 30. he like crushed
brill
yeah i don't know if this adds effective
or not it's so cutthroat it's almost so
cutthroat it's like
well it's almost like you guys look like
some yeah these people kind of look come
off like dr brill's like i
endorse this message it's like what
what did you put together man
so go start they all warned us and now
gosar is [ __ ] helping
you know the confederacy come back again
paul gosar oh do you know he responded
no he said you can't pick your family we
all have crazy aunts and relatives etc
and my family is no different
i hope they find peace in their hearts
and let go of all the hate [ __ ]
these are your
siblings these aren't your aunts and
relatives this is your brothers and
sisters dude
i just looked it up that district um
gosar had has won elections there
uh several in a row but prior to gosar
it was a democratic district for a long
time so it's not like it was fired yeah
he said to the six angry democrat
ghost stars see you at mom and dad's
house
jesus i don't know how you have
thanksgiving dinner after that one
i'm so curious what happened with this
family so anyway that's getting ghost
hard which apparently is just the
biggest betrayal of all time you all
thought
brutus julius caesar no ghosts are
anyway so we've got andrew yang
on the line he wants to talk to us about
his run to become the mayor
of new york city i'm very excited to
hear from andrew let's throw it to
andrew yang with us is
andrew yang as you all know and love
friend of the show
progressive he was in the presidential
race and now
he has an announcement that went out
yesterday the whole world is ready
andrew
what is the announcement thank you ethan
thank you gila i am running for
mayor of the greatest city in the world
new york city
mayor angie yang i love it what a better
man i mean you know the most progressive
city one of the most progressive cities
one of the progressive men forward
thinking
slick like new york itself oh wow well
thank you guys
we might need to move to new york yeah
you have to move to new york we will
welcome you with open arms do we get any
subsidies what can you do for us
a crazy broadcast studio and then we
will get you
a whole slew of wannabe h3 ethan and
gilas that you can take under your wing
and build some kind of content empire
what do you think
that's what happens i just want those
kickbacks now that i got a friend in
government hopefully i want those
governments maybe i'll i'll get you a
contract to like paper road
yeah exactly
exactly just get me like a 10 million
dollar contract to pay for
government great andrew happy birthday
by the way
yeah thank you so what is your platform
for the great
city of new york the first thing
is we have to try and become the fastest
comeback
city from covid and you all have been
indoors for a long time new york city
though
uh it's very very rough what's going on
because
if you uh have 60 million tourists not
show up
that supported over 300 000 jobs uh then
those jobs disappear
midtown manhattan is 75 unoccupied in
terms of commercial real estate subway
ridership is down
two-thirds or so a number of families
have left
so the biggest thing we have to do is
accelerate the comeback from covid by
making new york city
the place to be if you want to work or
go to a show
or get together at a restaurant or bar
in a way that's safe as we get
vaccinated so one of my big plans
if we're still in the throes of this
which unfortunately i think we will be
is to have essentially a digital
passport where it only has one piece of
information
and that's that you've been vaccinated
so if you can imagine going someplace
like a broadway theater and then just
saying been vaccinated you can go take
your mask off and you can be in a crowd
of hundreds of people knowing that
everyone there is perfectly safe
so new york city needs to lean in those
kinds of measures
because without that kind of move new
york city is going to struggle to
to reopen at the same level so what is
the digital passport what does that mean
is that something just on your phone is
that something a separate device how
does that
implement it oh it's really basic
uh because i'm a simple guy when it
comes down to it so
i have not been vaccinated um but after
you get vaccinated the universal thing
that happens
is that you get noted as being
vaccinated in a database either at the
state or federal level
and you get a vaccination card that says
who you are
and when you've been vaccinated so the
plan is to ask people
to simply scan that card uh we'll read
it the same way we do a check
we can also confirm it against the
database and then after you get the
the confirmation then you have something
on your phone that says
uh ethan was vaccinated in april
and he's good to go uh for 10 months or
a year or whatever it is
and so then when you show up to that
broadway theater you can just say like
been vaccinated and the only piece of
information on the phone
in this new york city app will be that
you were vaccinated in april and then
you're good to go
critics of that may call it like uh
well the critics will call it orwellian
because they don't know what orwellian
means
but what would you respond how would you
respond to someone miscategorizing that
as orwellian
well i i agree with the fact that
requiring though i think everyone should
vaccinate
um and i'm going to vaccinate it as soon
as anyone lets me
but i think requiring a vaccination is a
very different thing than requiring it
for uh attendance at a concert or a show
or a theater you know like there's no
one forcing you to go to the show
so so people have to make their own
decisions but if you're
the mayor of new york city you have to
encourage people
to be able to get together in groups or
offices uh and the best way to do that
is to give people a piece of mind
well if you guys can succeed there you
know
it can succeed everywhere so it's really
important that
that new york is able to flourish like
like the vision you have because i feel
like it sets the rest of the country up
for success
um what do you make of all these
vaccinations are just sitting on the
shelf
i mean is this something that you're
going to get involved with we have
with the rollout of the vaccinations in
america has been abysmal
you know we're only at a few percentage
points here where like if you look at a
country like israel which is already at
like 30 40
vaccination why isn't it going so slow
in america and do you think that it
should just be whoever wants it
gets it well i'm not someone who wants
to blame trump for everything but his
administration has completely botched
the
vaccine rollout and what they did is
they said to each state come up with
your own plan
so then each state has adopted different
uh
different rollouts i would suggest that
the big thing you should emphasize with
your rollout is that doses don't get
wasted
um so if you try and be overly precise
and say look we're just gonna
target this specific group let's call it
over 75 or people in a certain
profession
the problem is then you wind up with
some excess
doses uh you know in each container or
some of the doses go bad or like storage
you know uh has problems so the big
principle we should have is that not a
single dose gets wasted
uh and so even if you have particular
groups that you're trying to target
you should say look like we're going to
make sure nothing gets wasted and so you
can have essentially like a cue or a
waiting list
the fact is if someone had me on a
waiting list where it was like look
if like some vac vaccine dose frees up
like you know you have this period of
time i'd be out of here
like if i got that message right now i
would end this just like
like trying to get it done we should not
be wasting a drop
because the faster we get vaccinated the
faster uh we can all get together again
you know is it true that circumcision
is part of your platform it's completely
not
are you forcing circumcision on all
citizens of new york city
um yeah yeah you know i mean i think you
probably understand the context it's
like
uh someone who is concerned about my
campaign is trying to you know like make
people think that
um like i'm for some extreme position
whereas when i'm
as you probably would imagine is that
parents should be able to decide
whatever they want for their kids
oh isn't that isn't that already what it
is
what's interesting is that um that there
are
some uh environments where parents are
pushing i know this because i've had
you know uh kids where people are pushed
towards certain practices
uh based upon um uh
healthcare professionals advising one
thing or another and i'm just saying
leave it to the parents
oh that's that seems reasonable
um another thing that came up you were
trending on twitter recently
something about living in a two-bedroom
apartment people are upset
pardon me about you saying imagine
living in a two-bedroom apartment
with your family in new york city was
that taken out of context what was the
context of that comment
oh yeah so they were asking about um
about my
frankly beaming into cnn when i was
uh working with them um and then i made
a comment about how the fact i have two
boys in school
uh and that you know it's tough to uh
beam in for
a national news appearance when you have
two uh kids who are in school
and you're in a two bedroom apartment
manhattan and then they took that quote
and ran with it in a particular way
um which you know it was like a i guess
a fun learning about
um you're in the dirty game now yeah
wow huh yeah it
you know it was like uh-huh like you
know i i certainly wouldn't have uh
like taken that quote out of context in
that way and i tried to make a thing out
of it
but i i think that some of the folks i'm
running against um you know try to
take advantage of it and spin it a
certain way um that's correct
this is this is your first kind of
political
run right this is your big well besides
president but like this this one your
your i think presidential you you were
thinking like
i'm not going to win but the mayor i
mean let's be honest
well even you said that you said that
you're like look this is big six
exceeded my expectations already but the
mayor
andrew yang mayor we see it so this is
your first time being the
the on the receiving end of this kind of
political attack
ads right i think that's accurate
and uh that the fact is when i was
running for president
no one saw any upside to attacking
andrew yang right
like that wasn't really like in the
playbook
uh but but this time i think we're gonna
see more negativity
and uh i knew that coming in honestly
like i just want to help my city get
back on its feet
i understand that there are certain
people who've been um planning
their mayoral run for years or decades
and then you know they're going to be
very displeased
um with my campaign um
but i'm also confident that new yorkers
know we need something a bit different
than we've been getting
uh that we're in the midst of a crisis
and we're gonna need a different kind of
leader to point the way out
uh so i'm i'm super pumped and i do want
to say to any of your watchers and
listeners
uh who live in new york city there's
something about new york city finance
that's magical where if you give
five bucks to my campaign uh then the
city will give
us forty dollars they match it eight to
one if you believe that
why is that yeah yeah so new york city
because you said it earlier ethan it's a
very progressive city and one of the
ways they want to be progressive
is they want folks to be able to run for
office and have small dollar donors
oh wow so really any new york city
resident who donates to
my campaign gets matched eight to one
damn up to the first 250 they contribute
and most people aren't going to donate
more than 250
i mean you know give 10 20 bucks but if
you give 10 20 bucks at yang for ny.com
the city will just come in
magically later and then give amazing
mile 80 or 160. well
well foot soldiers in new york city you
know what to do
andrew you know it's funny when they
when trump got elected they were saying
this is a different
candidate this is the person we need i
actually feel that's
actually true about you i feel thank you
that andrew yang is the future he is the
governor
the govern not the governor but the kind
of governor
you know as a pronoun not you're not
running for governor
you're the mayor we understood you the
kind of lowercase g like yeah
lowercase
i want to ask you one last thing before
you go lauren bobert
q anon congressman who tweeted out the
location of nancy pelosi during the
capital riot what do we do with her do
we
what is going on with some of these new
members of the congress i mean
there should be some very very serious
repercussions to the capitol hill riots
i
mean
like that was like a nightmare come to
life yeah uh people died
a lot of folks have gotten confused
about appropriate political
communication and then incitement of
violence and extremism
and if you have elected officials acting
like that it's even worse uh you know it
it really poisons the the well um so i
hope that
someone um has her take those
actions uh you know much more seriously
and hopefully she has some
um consequences because there are a
number of folks
as another example i just saw at least
two or three members of congress have
come
down with covet as a result of being
trapped in that room together
and some of the republicans refused to
wear a mask
how do we function as a society when we
have congress people refusing to wear
masks
in the capital it's just beyond belief
it's so
believed so frustrating and you know now
the story
is developing is that three members of
congress were helping the rioters
give them information i saw that there's
some kind of like tours of the capital
yeah like someone said that their panic
button was removed
uh just total bat [ __ ] insanity
yeah uh that that seems to have made
this
even darker than it was and it was
already like a national nightmare well i
heard i heard the
the fbi spokesman they did a um
they did a conference the other day and
he says everything what
everything that you guys are going to
hear in the coming days and weeks is
going to be is going to blow your mind
so there's some sinister [ __ ] coming up
but regardless of all that
i'll feel a lot better knowing that
andrew yang is in charge of the crown
jewel of the united states new york city
we wish you all the
best and we're hoping that all the super
troopers out in new york city are making
a donation to what was the website
yang4ny.com you guys are gonna have to
come visit hopefully by that point we'll
be traveling again but i will host you
at gracie mansion
yeah you can have a special h3 from
gracie yes i would love
to i'll take you up on that big time i
would love to do that
i would be really relieved knowing that
someone like you has
any power yes you're the kind of people
i want to see
in power yeah we're just so tired of
seeing the same thing
people i think i saw youth wait like i'm
so tired of hearing what can't be done
or what yeah why we couldn't do
something
she's so tired of hearing that i mean
you hit the nail on the head earlier
uh both of you where israel uh is going
to vaccinate the entire population
by let's call it april uh you know and
and in april i have a feeling
you'll still be indoors this is america
this is we
we we mobilized for world war ii we are
the sleeping giant
why the [ __ ] can't we get vaccinations
out we should be
doing the model for the rest of the
world what happened to american
exceptionalism
we're just dog [ __ ] with all due respect
and this is what we have to turn around
like the fundamental challenge is
getting our bureaucracies to function at
a higher level
uh and i think i can help like i'm going
to tackle the bureaucracies in new york
city in a particular way
um and see if we can't actually solve
our problems in a way that gives people
confidence
and does not leave us like you just said
gila explaining why we couldn't do
something mm-hmm
well best of luck uh
new york for yang or what
we'll put a yeah in the description guys
if you want to
four downl it's actually the word for
where did you get the number one i never
did that we gotta get you andrew
yang.com i mean what's happening we also
have andrew yang dynasty
director does that redirect i think
you'll read it
[Laughter]
regardless of how you find them we wish
you all the best and thank you and good
luck and god bless
thank you so much appreciate the heck
out of you all right
take care good luck appreciate you so
finally here i got to ask you a question
okay vice news made this piece about
inside the capitol hill riot do you
recognize that person in the thumbnail
i mean i know it's small
let me see if i can zoom in with some
control plus action
so you have zoomed in a little bit do
you recognize that person
it looks like shoe nice like a lot like
shoe nice
those are resemblance so it's popping up
the video
a lot of people have been posting this
and showing it and apparently
even shu has been being reported to the
fbi apparently he said people have been
reporting it
but you you be the judge
who is that and they kind of even sound
like him a little bit
let's do it in slow-mo okay here's a
still frame
let me do a slow-mo
horrible that looks a lot like chewy
i've been snorting drain the wall all
day oh
wow it looks like him but not quite
right like it's
it could be him but it could maybe not
be him too
yeah i don't think she was motivated
enough to go out there and do that
that's my thing i think she was just
you know what i mean he's always bumming
around i don't i don't think he
i don't think he's got the he's too
famous for this yeah he's kind of too
boot right
i don't think it's you well
regardless let's just ask him i got him
on the phone right now i want to know
because i'm sure the fbi is going to
come knocking at his door so he might as
well set the record straight here now
you know what i mean what do you guys
think
i mean i certainly agree it looks a lot
like him but uh
i i zoomed way in on it and i don't
think it's him
yeah i don't think so but god damn
that's a lot of resemblance maybe a
cousin or some [ __ ]
shoe mean it looks like he's got a
little bit of gray hair on the side too
you see that i don't think uh she was
that great well regardless let's just
ask the man himself let's see shoe nice
let's get him on the line and find out
was he at the maga riot let's find out
shoe how are you
it's crazy bro right we knew that
[Laughter]
sure are you drinking again no i was
gonna start a beer review channel but
it's just in a beer review
this is old and lean i had one beer
since last august um
i don't believe that baby didn't you see
him slamming something
their old videos i'm uploading i'm
trying to get all the videos that people
stole for me because i found out that
there's actual liquor slams
that are people are making google
adsense revenue off of
and that's why i got kicked off of
youtube
so so you're not drinking alcohol
because everybody thought you were back
on the wagon
i'm on the way you never got off the
other way
yeah on the wagon
you're off i have no choice anymore guys
i mean my liver
right it got pretty bad but it came back
around and
you're gonna be okay so why so tell me
this
i guess now that you're sober as your
new past time trying to overthrow the
government because
we clearly saw you at the capitol riots
is there gonna be support with this are
you guys gonna
you know have the fbi in my house either
way
um if you take a really good close-up
look um
you can see the grayness i got brown
hair yeah i'm gonna pull this up
let's watch this clip real fast it's
funny that it's also the thumbnail for
this video they're like
you know what vice did that on purpose
they emailed me
at the capitol yeah they it's a weird
relationship they do a documentary on me
then they put it on tv and they owe me a
ton of syndication money
because that's tv what did they email
your story
they just said hey was that you at the
capitol and i thought it was a joke but
i'd recognize the new york city numbers
from vice when i was on the show
so i think they put me on as a thumbnail
busting my butt i mean it looks just
like you but i do you have
do you have a missing brother no
you have an alibi more like matt damon
doesn't he that guy
he's a little matt you're right
so have you been contacted by the fbi or
anything
no i mean with his face he was really
not past the barricade so
there's no um evidence of him even
pushing the fence and he just turned
around he's seen the cameras and said
stop the steel and i think he just ran
away
so whoever that is not saying you
there's no evidence that
this man committed a crime
bro the haters are having a field day
with that 1 800 tips
number oh this guy's a youtuber trump
fan
because somebody made a video calling
the fbi and i'm just like
oh haters will be haters really yeah
well on a real note i actually i could
see that it's not you
you think so yeah are you that good
no i saw you wait there was a video plus
i bust balls ethan i bust balls i've
never voted in my life for student
council in high school i wrote my own
name in for vice president
i just i i don't let the government
control my path
of existence on planet earth i saw you
doing a video saying you were a proud
boy
no if i was then it's just busting balls
like saying i loved hillary clinton and
i wanted her to win
you know it's just i always like to um
make waves in the pool
and there's a lot of people out there
it's so easy to get under their skin
and i've been doing that since the fifth
grade playground
all right well so we've cleared your
name fbi if you are watching it was not
you
is it is there anything else you want to
pass on
yeah i'm sober i started skateboarding
today for the first time at 51 years old
um i think we should just get together
maybe twice a month
where we just you know are you guys
going to have um people on your show
again are you pushing towards more just
you know oh it's covered once over and
we're moving to our new spot we're gonna
we'll be having people and i'd love to
have you want to do some kick flips for
us
yeah i'll be i'll be a couple hours
outside of la probably
i'd say two weeks had to come back to
colorado
square up some stuff clear out some
storage units but
i think it's a third leg on h3h3 bro
which is going to be maybe not twice a
month that seems kind of a lot
all right maybe once every two months
i'm sorry i don't go to aaa and i have a
coin to prove to you that i'm sober but
you don't need a a in a book and all
these coins to quit alcohol
you know it's just that's for weak
minded people and half the people in an
aaa meeting cheering you on
are just people with duis trying to
impress the judge you know what i mean
excuse me yes but yeah it's good to see
you guys man um
like i said california i'm gonna go to
san luis obispo
probably gonna start surfing once i get
my balance on the skateboard you know
the world is my oyster once you got that
balance the whole world opens up
yeah my newest video on my youtube i
tried skateboarding for the first time
today
they call me tony bach you know what i
mean
sure all right chilly well take care
stay appreciated man
we want you to be talking you guys i'm
sober and like i said i'm an entertainer
i could add so much conversation to any
interview absolutely
well guys so ends another episode
hope you guys enjoyed we'll be back on
friday live for after dark
next week we are going to be hopefully
doing four episodes we've got
the we'll work on course we're working
on this content we want to make it
perfect so it's been a work in progress
for a while
you know we are going after the king and
when you go
after the king you best not miss right
so we'll make sure it's perfect
so looking forward to that next week
until then we'll see you on friday i
hope you had a lot of fun here today
remember to hit that join button if you
want to become a member get the episodes
the evening before they go live get them
a half a day early
night before
hope because of staying safe and where's
your best all right
either would you like to eat for now is
appropriate time to discuss start you
can hit play the music down we'll just
be like
so what are you doing for lunch you're
going to go to the office or you want to
order like you know when newscasters are
chit-chatting
yeah what are you doing for lunch i have
to go to the office
what are you gonna do for lunch so
yourself to eat i'm gonna starve
that's not appropriate you're not gonna
eat anything
i don't know you want me to make
something for you sure
do you want me to make something for you
you want me to make like pasta
i don't have time well then you better
get something on the way to eat because
you have to eat food
okay um did we talk enough on camera
about what i'm gonna eat well i think
people want to know what you're gonna
eat so
i can cook i can heat something up for
you you better are you gonna stop and
get something on the way
avocado sandwich i can make avocado
sandwich okay one black olive
and mozzarella cheese yeah for extra
calories okay good okay